Okay, good morning, good evening, Maxie, how are you?
Good morning, Hello!
Okay, today I will talk
about learning languages in German.
I'm talking to Maxie
Maxie has a channel for
Learning German,
called German in Tokyo, but
You live in Osaka, don't you?
Yes exactly.
Maybe can you explain a little bit about yourself?
Why and how is that you live in
Tokyo or Osaka
in German?
I started speaking Japanese almost 12 years ago
and then I studied in Japan
and I always study Japanese
got to know who learned German,
and because I learned Japanese, I just enjoyed it because Japanese
to teach studying German.
Yes, that's how I started.
I mostly make videos on my YouTube channel
in Japanese to learn German or about German culture.
And most of the Japanese who want to learn German
So what are the main motives?
Main reasons why they want to learn German
I think a lot of people are interested in classical music.
and that's why you want to go either to Germany, Austria, Vienna,
and stop studying classical music
play the piano and then stop
this is the one group
the other group that are
the men who care for Germans
There is also history, but more like philosophy.
Yes, and there is also a group of Japanese people who want to go on vacation to Germany,
and that's why you want to learn a little German for your vacation.
So for me German is very interesting, so Germany, Austria also a bit,
You can communicate in German in Switzerland.
And there is a lot of history and a lot of nice people.
But the German language has a lot of grammar.
Yes.
for example Slavic languages,
then I won't focus much on these grammatical rules
exactly the same with the other language, I speak very badly in German now, because
But one question. I read a book in German.
Lets begin here, geläst and gelesen?
Gelesen.
I mean in German, the difficulty with German, for example, we say "Ich habe gesagt" and then we also say "Ich habe gesprochen".
So the past participle on some verbs, that is
we say to a T, that is, said, done
and on the other verbs we have an N,
Geläst or gelesen.
So I often think that many Japanese learn too much grammar.
And when you learn too much grammar it becomes difficult to speak
when you have all the rules in your head.
So I think it's more important to hear a lot.
And to find German friends.
So you can in the internal, veil when you speak,
then it's easier. But as a Japanese, I recommend learning grammar in Japanese,
because it is easier to explain than in German.
Sometimes it is good when Japanese German teachers explain grammar because they have also learned German as a foreign language speaker.
But there are many rules in German
but there are many exceptions, that means you always have to be careful.
These explanations, so why do you have to get a new habit, as you say,
I've completely forgotten my German. It doesn't matter to me, I make mistakes, I've forgotten a lot of words, but it doesn't matter to me.
How is that when I said succeed, spoken, said.
I think most of the cases I use the verb, I say
laughed but spoken, but that's not because I know the rules
So now I haven't heard German for a long time, but I've heard German.
In the 1990s I was in Germany a lot, I did a business there, I read books.
So that has become a bit automatic.
And when I don't have the opportunity to speak German, it's a little worse.
But anyway, I don't do it through explanations, that's through practice, listening, reading, speaking.
And not by these rules.
Yes, I think so, too. So the problem with rules is that
there are always exceptions, and once you start to learn rules,
then it becomes more difficult to speak.
In your head you think about the rules
and you have such a blockade.
It's just important to practice
stop speaking, and above all listen a lot, so you can.
There is now a lot in German, there are audio books.
Fenomenal, excellent audio books in German. It's a language like Russian
that's not the case with Japanese. Very little good audio books in Japanese.
But in German, in Swedish, in Russian, a great many, very nicely done.
I've read a book, there's a brain researcher
his name is Manfred Spitzer. And he said he also has a video on YouTube,
Our brains are not designed to remember details.
It is very difficult, we will forget all the details.
but our brains are very good at templates, models,
Make patterns through this very many details
that we have already forgotten will become new ones
Develop paterns.
And that's what allows us, how do you say enabled,
Allowed is correct.
allows you to speak this language. Because we have these patterns, these models. But these details
we will always forget and learn again and forget again.
And I also think, for example, I also speak Japanese and English,
It is very difficult to speak Japanese, but then learn to speak English
much easier because i already knew a language.
The more languages ​​you learn, the easier it is to remember these groups.
Yeah that's right, but I can't get the grammatical details, it really is
it's hard to remember
but you hear it a bit and then you use it.
And I think you are right
The more languages ​​you learn, sometimes there is interference,
But I don't think that's important. Man has more and more self-confidence,
because now I know that I can learn to speak.
Then learn Arabic, it's a matter of time.
It will take longer to learn Arabic than Italian.
But I know I can do that. And a brain has the ability too
Learning languages ​​has improved.
by learning other languages.
That's always a plus. You can now learn Chinese language.
Korean.
Hungarian maybe. Yes, exactly.
That's why I believe the people in Europe
They live if you live in Germany, France, or Belgium, which I don't go far.
In a few 100 km you will have another language.
That is not the case in Japan.
And not in Russia or the USA either.
And because of this, many Europeans find it easier to learn languages.
Many Japanese always ask me if it makes sense to learn German,
because I don't even speak English properly
but I think if you learn an additional language,
then it will be easier to learn English afterwards.
Certainly because, for example, a Japanese
who learn German, it will be difficult, a lot of work,
Work for the brain, but English becomes easier afterwards.
For example, if you do weightlifting.
When you lift difficult weights
then the lighter ones become lighter.
And when you learn several languages, there are connections between German and English.
Also between English and French.
And if you then learn another language, you learn a different way of thinking,
and learns some vocabulary that is more important
in German than in English and the other way arround.
And that helps. This is a development
with his ability to learn languages.
And I think, being a Japanese, we all live on the same earth.
We are allowed to learn several languages, Japanese, German, Swedish,
Arabic. You are not trying too much weight or emphasis
to put on grammar.
Yes, I think so, too.
That's right, okay, thank you.
I need to practice more, okay, bye.
Good luck, bye.